it's been one of my pleasures in my many
visits to New Haven to do so in
connection
often with seeing in and working on
projects and we've got a couple still in
the works which I really look forward to
seeing coming to completion I want to
start off again by thanking Nicholas
semanas and Erika de bruin for
organizing these lectures I very much
appreciate that mr. castle for four
founding these lectures I want to thank
she wasn't able to get here mrs. Julie
kid whose grant from the Christian
Johnson endeavor Foundation has funded a
great deal of my research and mostly my
research assistance over the past few
years and I especially want to thank all
of you for sharing your Thursday
afternoons in October with me discussing
non-intervention and intervention I was
going to summarize a little bit of what
I've said so far but Ian did that so
well let me skip over that very briefly
but as he mentioned I'm working with
three principles the principle of
national security the principal
humanitarian protection and the
principle of collective self
determination and together they justify
a very strong presumption against
intervention the non-intervention
principle last week I showed how those
same principles could be used to
override the presumption against
intervention and I talk then about an
internationalized Civil War and some of
the dangers associated with that and to
bring it home I talked a little bit
about the expedition to new haven and
1562 I then talked about ending
protracted civil wars on how that
provides an occasion from a humanitarian
point of view that if the war keeps
going on and on and on at some point
sympathetic external powers may want to
step in and try to mediate a solution
and for their I referred as John Stuart
Mill did to some obscure but important
events in Portugal in 1846 and then I
spent most of the lecture on
humanitarian intervention why from the
standpoint of common humanity one would
might want to rescue a population
subject to massacres that shocked the
conscience of mankind or genocide and
there I heard to the contemporary
example of Libya this week I'm looking
at another set of considerations that
can favor intervention
rather than overriding with moral
concerns like humanitarian protection or
national security here I want to talk
about disregarding non-intervention that
is because there are principles that
lead us to non-intervention especially
the self-determination principle that
just do not apply in some cases there's
more than one nation on the same piece
of sovereign territorial of territory
and then the question is which nation
should be the authentic nation that
needs to be respected or alternatively
one big nation is oppressing another
smaller nation and to say that it should
arduously struggle to define its
existence is unrealistic maybe immoral
or thirdly there some societies mill
will present to us that he thinks are
just incapable of expressing nationality
so I want to talk about these kind of
concerns today from mill he talks about
this as another category the disregarded
where he says the factors that interests
him operate in an opposite way he said
then he continues the reasons themselves
do not exist an intervention he
continues I quote does not disturb the
balance of forces on which the permanent
maintenance of freedom in a country
depends he wants to see country struggle
for their own identity that's why
non-intervention is so important but
there are some circumstances under which
that presumption against non against
intervention should be disregarded and
that's what I want to talk to today he
develops three cases I want to focus on
the first is national liberation or call
it the ethics of secession and the
recognition and maybe even the support
for a secessionist movement this is a
case where there are too many nations on
one piece of sovereign territory or
where an imperial government opposes the
independence of a subordinate nation two
different distinct peoples each
attempting perhaps to crush the other
there is no presumption that one of them
is automatically the right one for that
single piece of territory they are in
competition with
each other what's missing is the one
nation that justifies us respecting its
collective self-determination and under
these circumstances foreigners can
sometimes intervene to assist a process
of secession or decolonization it goes
by a variety of different labels in
Mills mind clearly he wrote in 1859 and
his wonderful little essay on
non-intervention he had in mind the
separation of America from Britain was
clearly in his mind but the case that he
focused most upon is the 1848 249
Hungarian rebellion against Austria and
there when he says once the secessionist
can establish local represent a
representative character internationals
can then legitimately assist them as the
French did in 1778 to assist the
American rebels and as if maybe Britain
could have should have in 1848 to assist
Hungary's rebellion from Austria and we
have contemporary examples of it today
of course andra trai from Ethiopia the
breakup of the former Soviet Union the
breakup of the former Yugoslavia
somaliland and it's de facto separation
from Somalia East Timor from Indonesia
controversially but they're all
controversial South Ossetia from Georgia
supported by Russia all these are
contemporary cases of nationalist
secessionist movements breaking away
from countries and of course perhaps the
most famous is Kosovo from Serbia and
there of course it's now de facto
independent and de jure a by matter of
law it's recognized as an independent
state by 82 countries most of them are
Muslim but also many in the European
Union and the u.s. all recognized but
significantly neither Russia nor Serbia
does the legality of the declaration of
independence by Kosovo recently went
before the International Court of
Justice but the ruling was incredibly
narrow they said that a declaration per
se is not illegal the court judgment but
they skipped on talking about whether a
secession is illegal or not though is a
very narrow ruling
as the court has been doing for the past
10 or 15 years so let me make a couple
comments about international law and
international ethics of secession of
that bounce off ideas in mil
international law is not fully coherent
on this question there are two doctrines
with regard to the recognition of new
states one of them is called the
constitutive theory which is that the
act of recognition by other states
legally constitutes a new and equal
state in the international system the
other is that the Clara Tory theory
which is that an active recognition
merely declares the objective existence
of another polity recognizing it as a
state when it has a fixed territory a
stable population when it has a
government that's capable of governing
and is capable of engaging Foreign
Relations these are the criteria now we
don't hold our state's to very strict
notions of those four criteria we all
know the United States did not have a
fixed boundary either in the north of
the West for many many years it was up
in dispute Israel another new state did
not have a fixed boundary when it was
found that it doesn't quite have one
today Palestine another candidate for
being a state certainly doesn't have a
fixed boundary and with Palestine it
doesn't even yet have a independent
government that is it's not functionally
independent it's under largely the
control of Israel so those have been
some of the criteria but the harder
question then recognition is whether a
people has a right to its own state and
that's when it gets much much more
difficult and this was totally dodged by
the International Court of Justice in
the Kosovo case under international
ethics or international norms that have
been bodied in declarations and that has
a certain customary character to it all
peoples have a right to
self-determination a UN declaration is
declared that's UN declaration in 1970
but it doesn't quite say what a people
is every people is right to
self-determination but what is a people
then becomes the question they refer to
language and cultural similarities you
won't be surprised in the Quebec case
which I think
the best discussion of this I've seen in
the in the legal literature this is the
Quebec case before the Supreme Court of
Canada in 1998 they've drew some very
interesting distinctions they said that
all peoples have a right to internal
self determination that is they have a
right to participate in their own
government's that is to have some of
their minority rights recognized
language rights for example variety of
minority rights they only have a claim
to external self-determination that is
creating their own state if and only if
they've been subject to colonial rule or
foreign occupation or then they refer to
something like where internal self
determination has been blocked those are
the three reasons that allow you to
translate your internal right to
self-determination but we would call
minority rights into an external right
to self-determination the right to have
your own country well the court then
proceeded in a very good opinion to say
that given Quebec Civic freedoms and the
very substantial participation of the
quebecois in wider Canadian politics
they found that neither of the three
exceptions held for Quebec and therefore
it had a right to internal
self-determination a recognition of its
special culture but nothing more than
that and quite Riley I thought the
justices went on to remark that 40 of
the past 50 years they're right in the
1998 in Canada were years in which the
Prime Minister of Canada was a quebecois
so it would be odd if they were being
permitted to secede it's a wonderful
opinion I can only recommend it to you
but nonetheless what really constitutes
a colonial rule situation or occupation
is very much up for dispute and during
much of the Cold War period from 1945 on
the operative definition was what we
call the salt water theory that is that
you had a right to external
self-determination having your own
country as long as salt water separated
you from the purported colonial superior
so all the colonies in Africa at and
asia had that right but none of the
contiguous states that were under
occupation or colonial oppression some
would say on the continents of Europe or
or the Americas so that were those were
the operative rules no that didn't help
very much when we came to the end of the
Cold War and the breakup of the USSR in
the former Yugoslavia there's no not
much salt water that separates the
various component units some of the
breakups were were read under the
foreign occupation doctrine so the
Baltic states were now freed from
foreign occupations they've been subject
to for the whole period of the Cold War
other parts of it were consensual that
is the the former Soviet Union broke up
into the sea is on a quasi consensual
basis but that didn't work for the
former Yugoslavia there when they began
to look to for constitutive borders that
is of this component republics of the
Yugoslav Federation that was used to
excuse Slovenia Croatia and others but
it left two big problems one of the
course was Kosovo which it had lost its
constitutive Republic status and the
other was the problem of the beached
minorities as it's been called that is
Serbs who were left in Croatia and in
Bosnia and elsewhere who still want to
be part in Serbia but were now found
they were Croatians or Bosnian Serb
Bosniaks or others you and so under that
confusion in the old Lockean fashion
they all appealed to heaven which meant
they went to war because there was no
other authority to distinguish that and
then we had the great crises of Kosovo
and others if we turn to international
ethics we also get some guidelines our
philosophers tell us that the right of
self-determination is rooted in
fundamental human rights and human
dignity it comes from as derivative from
our right of self-rule extended into a
collective framework but there that's
often been seen that one looks for
collective identities that can help
identify who it is with whom one can
collectivize into a new political unit
and one approach to this is ethnographic
in subjective they're the scholars look
to cultural historical democratic
standards
that constitute a legitimate claim for
independence philosophers such as
mazzini have made large claims such as
to each nation its own state every
nation should have a state every nation
is equal every nation gets the equal
right to have a state and then and then
we see that they regard the state as
having a powerful role in helping to
both protect and at the same time
perpetuate a national cultural identity
through education and other means
complementarity philosophers draw our
attention to the fact that states tend
to be more stable when they have a
consistent national identity underlying
them meal himself argued this at one
point or another and states we can see
cultivate national unity for the sake of
stability and so for example they
establish national churches and they
establish languages the french academy
made sure that the longed we won out
over all of its rivals including the
lone duck independent ireland fostered
not so successfully but with a lot of
effort earth's as a national language of
the Croatians today got their state and
now the state is busily creating a
Croatian language on the basis of the
previously shared language of
serbo-croatian shared with Serbia and
Bosnia and elsewhere mill as i mentioned
thought that a single national identity
would stabilize a state mazzini went on
to make a large and important claim that
when a nation and a state orca
tournament that is when every nation is
satisfied with its own state then we're
likely to have international peace a
peace amongst satisfied nation-states
was his argument and that was the good
news and we can see that this is not
just the musings of philosophers we can
see a similar kind of discourse in
actual declarations of independence when
real statesmen get out there and talk
about these questions and we can see
they're wonderfully diverse and they
also but they also have some typical
patterns a building on some very
interesting work by David Armitage he
shows that even some language gets
translated think of these words all men
are created equal they are endowed by
their creator with certain inalienable
rights among these are life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
that comes from we all know the
Vietnamese declaration of independence
of 1945 yes that is a direct quote from
them that they borrowed very
self-consciously so these words show up
again Oh Joshua Simon here at Yale as it
tells me these engaged in a very
interesting project looking at the
ideologies a declaration of independence
in the Americas looking for similarities
amongst them so there's a lively
scholarship to this field I've observed
and looking at a variety of declarations
some of the following patterns one they
start out with an attempt to provide a
justification a rationale if you will
for their act of independence it often
in some of the classic ones gets focused
on human equality we're fellow human
beings we have the same right to rule
ourselves as any others it is
self-evident for example that we have
these rights words from Jefferson but
some of them also start off on another
basis the wonderful Declaration of
Independence of 1804 from Haiti that was
lost for a long time but recently
rediscovered talks about race and racial
oppression as the justification for an
independent Haiti and they certainly had
historical evidence to support the the
the right that they had to end their
oppression on the flip side the Tecla
the Texas Declaration of 1861 says that
the Union which they call the
Confederacy meaning the earlier one that
is the 1787 one was founded on the
principle that it's exclusively and I
quote for the white race and now they
see the federal government in Washington
is undermining that what they saw as a
fundamental basis of the Confederation
of 1787 or in one of my favorites you
can find a whole rich mix of hodgepodge
of justifications the Israel Declaration
of Independence of 1948 has talked about
the Bible as a source of of the of the
Independence of the Jewish people but
also they throw in secular things
including a wonderful claim that the
immigrants made the Desert Bloom and
then they throw in international
authorities like the Balfour Declaration
and UN resolution a
181 all of this is thrown in for the
justification of independence in 1948
the second thing we see our grievances
it's not enough to say that we're all
fellow human beings that we can rule
ourselves almost all of them recognizes
that an act of secession of independence
is a is a shocking break and so they
look to show that the previous rule
wasn't not just their rule but it was in
some way illegitimate and that's part of
the grievances that one can see in our
own declaration the long train of abuses
that's two-thirds of our declaration is
this long bill of indictment of
absolutely everything they could think
of that the British had done wrong in
the Americas but we can find that
elsewhere in the Irish Declaration of
1919 they Chronicle you wouldn't be
surprised 700 years of oppression as a
reason for independence in 1919 the only
match to that I've seen is the Georgian
Declaration of Independence this is
Georgia in the Caucasus where they say
almost 800 years of oppression has
justified their separation the most
recent one is that of the mosquito
nation which declared its independence
in 2009 by in a declaration issued by
mr. Hector William the great judge of
the mosquito people that is a people
inside Nicaragua they haven't yet
succeeded they traced two years of
self-rule as a basis for it but then
they go on to complain about recent
restrictions by the Ortega government on
turtle hunting which is part of their
traditional culture so they too are
making an effort to become a independent
state and then of course thirdly there's
usually a claim that's the last resort
that is they've tried a lot of other
things so Jefferson says they've
petitioned for redress in the most
humble terms but the tyrannical prints
and even the British people have not
listened to them and lastly it winds up
with the claim the right of being a free
and independent an equal state with all
other states and a pledge of some sort
of joint action in the US Declaration
its pledge of Our Lives our Fortunes our
sacred honor so that's what the strong
claims we can see and they resonate in
law philosophy and in the declarations
the need to justify secession and
independence but there's also some bad
news that we know that's associated with
it the problem of minorities within
minorities you know one minorities the
seeds only to have within it another
minority that regards that rule is
illegitimate this is still being worked
out in Kosovo with the Serb minority in
the north regarding the government of
Kosovo's totally illegitimate and not
their own even worse are our populations
that secede when they're not even the
majority and from some data put together
it looks like the Abkhaz who seceded
from Georgia when the at the time of
their secession were about seventeen
percent of the population and yet they
seceded and they've been ethnically
cleansing the country ever since to
become a majority so these are big moral
or ethical and also legal problems but
the largest problem associated with
secession and self-determination is that
if we regard language as an indicator or
a marker for for identity there are some
6,000 languages that the ethnographers
have identified and unfortunately we've
only got 190 plus countries at the
present time so one nation one country
is going to be put under a great deal of
stress now fifty two percent of those
languages are spoken by fewer than
10,000 people so let's assume we can
forget about that it's only a small
number but that still leaves us a
troublesome 2,800 currently unsatisfied
potential claimants on statehood and
moreover seventeen percent of those
languages are spoken in more than one
state leaving us with potential diaspora
or ranch lush issues that still would
have to be dealt with so Robert Lansing
Wilson Secretary of State who himself
was deeply involved in this process of
self-determination mused during the
Paris Peace Conference to himself and to
some of his friends and to Wilson which
is why got fired the phrase is simply
loaded with dynamite it will raise hopes
which never can be realized it will I
fear cost thousands of lives that's a
quote the only thing wrong about his
coat is that he was off by orders of
magnitude
in terms of the lives that cost so
there's a second proach a second
approach if we can't complete the
nation-state system give every nation
its own state we have another way of
looking at the problem of nationality
which seems more promising and this is
approach I'd call inter-communal
procedure ilysm here any claim can be
put on the table and then including the
claim to secession but before derived
its accession it has to undergo a set of
procedures which validate and hopefully
moderate at least to explore where
there's something short of secession
will satisfy the identity aspirations of
the group that's making the claim and I
prefer to a draft convention it's called
the Liechtenstein draft convention on
self-administration and
self-determination it's floating around
hoping for signatures it's got very few
signatures but that doesn't take away
from its intellectual merits it sets up
a commission that would help mediate
these kinds of conflicts and launch a
consensual process or some community
which thinks it needs to have its
identity better recognized and that has
a certain geographic basis to it
approaches the Commission with the
permission of its state and begins a
process whereby its identity is realized
first only at the local level through
administration maybe its own language
schools may a police force that's fluent
in its own language and then a period of
time ensues under which its then
determined is that sufficient to satisfy
the claims that are being made and if
not they go back to the Commission and
then stronger forms of
self-administration even raising up to
the issue may be their own quasi
legislation for the province or zone
that they happen to be predominant in
and that also is given series of time to
see if that's sufficient and then only
if that's not can a claim be made
provided this group has proved itself as
capable of administrating respecting
human rights rule of law kind of
engagement that is truly representative
for a claim of secession and
independence which then the commission
would rule upon that's the procedural
one and it's one of course that's in
many respects quite attractive
it's not however a panacea in any means
it could obviously create a plethora of
small states so Liechtenstein would
certainly have a lot of company all
sorts of other little Lichtenstein's out
there created around the world but it
only works in ideal situations I look at
this is sort of like a marriage
counseling service for national
self-determination and many divorces are
not velvet and the few that are like the
checks in the slow Vox this is a lovely
process that could assist them but for
many it simply won't work there will be
Kosovo's east talk demores south ossetia
and many more and therefore we have to
face up to the difficulties I think that
under some circumstances without a
formula we can support or even should
support a bit of national secession with
international assistance and me maybe
even under extreme cases force if one
can see that a group has to generally
organized itself that it's
representative it proves that it can
sacrifice and rule itself in a way that
respects human rights and will provide
itself the opportunity of being a decent
member of the international community
when other alternatives have been tried
especially when they've been effort to
try things like self-administration and
they haven't worked and instead the
majority government the state sovereign
and takes measures to oppress them and
after you made an effort to take this
through multilateral processes such as
the Security Council under those
circumstances one can imagine that it
the only right thing to do would be to
provide international support even in
some circumstances by force and that's
what mill opens up to us when he talks
about the Hungarian case as you may know
mill thought it would been right for the
British to assist the Hungarians and
their independence but the British
weren't simply not prepared to do it was
too dangerous but for him it would have
been the right thing to do and we can
think of some other examples in history
but there aren't many and the sad thing
is is that we haven't fully established
the kind of procedures that would tap
into the lesser demands for self
administration and instead these
conflicts tend to escalate to the ones
to self-determination and secession and
caught up in all sorts of violence let
me briefly look at a second one and I'm
going to do this very quickly and that's
the issue of counter intervention in an
ongoing civil war mill really believes
that civil wars are a form of of them of
politics that are themselves self
determining that is it's through the
struggle that a rebel group proves
itself fit to be able to govern a
country it's a very hard hard message
that he gives but he thinks that that
should be only fought amongst the local
participants one side versus another
side it's up to them and that struggle
is the self determining method in which
a new government if it's a revolutionary
government is constituted and so the one
thing he does not accept is that if one
outside power intervenes that is not
legitimate but if they have intervened
under those circumstances you could
counter intervene supporting the other
side in the in the factional struggle so
that therefore it's the domestic
struggle which then determines the
outcome so you can you can't you
shouldn't intervene but if somebody else
intervenes you can counter intervene
because doing so then make sure that the
collective self determination is
determined by local forces rather than
foreign forces and Milligan has in mind
the Hungarians he thought that they
might have had a legitimate rebellion
against Austria but even if they didn't
he was absolutely sure that Russia
should not have intervened on Austria
side in that civil war and that if
Austria did and I quote if Russia gave
assistance to the wrong side England
would aid the right was his claim it did
not but he's thought they should have a
second reason why there should have been
an intervention in 1848 to support the
Hungarians others have discussed the
Vietnam War in the 1960s and in some for
some this was a case of North Vietnam
intervening in South Vietnam justifying
the u.s. counter intervening against the
North Vietnamese intervention that takes
away the fact of Vietnam is
as an entity but nonetheless South
Vietnam was a recognized state so was
North Vietnam of the u.s. memorandum
Leonard Meekers memorandum of 1965 i
believe it was put forth the case along
these lines my only comment is there is
that it makes logical sense that is on
the grounds of self-determination you
want the locals to do it if somebody
else intervened you can intervene only
to the extent you balance them in the
million arguments of the local factors
decide it makes logical sense but it
doesn't make very much practical sense
what you tend to create into those
circumstances and what we talked about
last week you tend to create a
protracted Civil War if foreigners are
helping to fund one of the participants
and you are helping to fund the other
you're going to produce a long term war
what immense devastation attached to it
that's one of the problems the Vietnam
experience is also not a strong
advertising for the counter intervention
thesis and in the political science side
a forthcoming SI by s ago Aiden and
Patrick Regan in the european journal of
international relation confirms the
significance of these concerns using
data from 1945 they've shown that
competitive counter interventions
lengthen civil wars the only
interventions that shorten them is if
the at the outside intervenors come down
on one side to support it but
competitive ones counter intervention
just make for longer civil wars in the
post-1945 period let me then move to my
last point the third and last disregard
this is benign imperialism those of you
have had a chance to skim the essay if
you hadn't read it before you would have
been surprised I suspect reading this
powerful at least fervent defense of
imperialism based upon liberal
principles which is what john stuart
mill is doing it's certainly his most
controversial disregard i want to talk
about that and then very briefly modern
peacebuilding mill says that the
allegedly barbarous non civilized world
in which he dumps most of Africa Asia
that is the 19th century colonial
empires were not parts of the world
which his doctrine of non-intervention
applied his doctrine only applied to
civilized countries not to non civilized
countries and he thought therefore that
benign imperialism was the right policy
not non-intervention in dealing with
those particular societies the example
he draws upon I think you noticed was
dude oh you de in India that's the
modern Awad province just east of the
province that the Taj Mahal is a little
bit east of the Delhi a very populous
province and it was annexed by Britain
in 1858 what are water mills arguments
for Imperial intervention he gives four
indictments of these societies that
justify in his view intervening to
control them in an imperial fashion
there are four debilitating infirmities
infirmities are despotism anarchy
immoral present ISM and famine is
important that are wrong with these
societies according to him that make
them incapable of self-determination and
therefore candidates for imperial rule
he says for example the people are
imposed upon and I quote by a despot so
oppressive and extortionate as to
devastate the country that's the
despotism despotism when it's long
endured in the country produces anarchy
characterized and I quote by such a
state of nervous imbecility that
everyone's subject to their will who had
not the means of defending himself by
his owned armed followers was the prey
of anybody who had a band of ruffians in
his pay warlords continually of
devastating and controlling every
community they could get a hand on third
people as a result deteriorate into a
moral present ISM in which present
gratification overwhelms the future and
no contracts can be relied upon and
fourthly moral duties extend no further
than the family national civic identity
is altogether absent those are the four
elements of his indictment of these
societies mill concludes that no
civilized government can maintain a
stable relationship of non-intervention
with these uncivilized societies he says
in the first place the rules of ordinary
morality implied reciprocity but
barbarians will not reciprocate that's
his argument and in the next place he
continues nations have not got beyond
the period these nations during which it
is likely be for their benefit that they
should be conquered and held in
subjection by foreigners in these
circumstances mill claims imperial rule
is the right thing the food it's a
benign colonialism it should be noted
it's the kind of paternalism that in
normal ethical discourse we reserve for
children or the mentally infirm who
presumably can benefit from nothing else
other than paternalism and that's the
argument that mill is making it's
important to note that mill is not
advocating either exploitation or
racialist domination he is a very strong
critic of the eggs of the existing
practices of Imperial exploitation in
the 19th century in time after time he
comes down on a as a critic of actually
existing Imperial practices at this time
he recommends what he calls a tolerant
form of a benign paternalism it's
neither totalitarian nor racist it does
not require that any of the peoples in
Africa or Asia adopt European or British
culture or civilization or religion it's
found that upon principles of
humanitarian protection that are deeply
embedded in its philosophy and that
elsewhere help justify non-intervention
so he doesn't require them to convert to
Christianity or adopt English culture
the only education that he seeks to
impose is an education in the rule of
law and in the rational material
sciences because he thinks that with
those two techniques if you will of
civilization they will then be launched
in a path the veggie
that will allow them to determine
themselves and to develop in the
progressive way that he thought was
appropriate so that's his claim for a
benign imperialism my question is what
should we make of this let's a few
things let us note that mill nowhere
demonstrates in this essay the kind of
present ISM that he claims that is that
these people can only think about the
present can't think about the future on
its face it's somewhat incredible when
we think about the worlds of Africa and
Asia in this period the generations of
Labor invested in great projects of art
the Taj Mahal Angkor Wat the Baneen
bronzes I was in Taipei last summer went
to the National Museum this is this
wonderful Jade boat and it was carved
over three generations one generation
teaching the next generation the
techniques teaching the next generation
the techniques and it took three
generations to make this one car boat
the idea that their present 'used is
quite difficult to believe under those
circumstances but on the other hand
anarchy and corruption and despotic
oppression did afflict many of the
peoples in this region to current
experts on the food awad region a
professor mukerji and a professor met
Clair actually agree with Mills
indictment of the Nawabs the rulers of a
wad or would they abandoned the attempt
to govern and amuse themselves with wine
women and poetry doesn't sound so bad
but they wasn't good for their people
needless to say in the view of of these
historians and if we can find other
sources that confirm the million
indictment that the rulers of awadh food
were less than responsible they were
characterized by gross and systematic
oppression anarchy and misrule in
another document by another Assessor
1837 but what's important is that mill
while he does accept some responsibility
on the part of Britain for the misrule
there doesn't fully take home the real
impact of previous British in
agement with food a wad before it was
annexed in 1858 and if we look into the
history we can go back to the Treaty of
1801 that treaty established a
protectorate over wood for which the
nawab paid a very heavy subsidy to the
east india company he guaranteed
unfettered access to British merchants
so no tariffs no control to protect the
British murthy local merchant uh he was
left without authority a British
resident was appointed there who had
access to armed troops and commercial
authority and he had to pay an annual
fee of 76 lakhs of rupees I've been I've
been told that that's about 3.8 million
dollars in eighteen fifty six dollars as
a fee being paid to the rulers of India
that's a great deal of money and so he
was left with no authority no money no
control over his economy wine women and
poetry was about all he had left and the
citta the people of food were subject to
totally inadequate rule under those
circumstances milk and point to what a
mess this place is and therefore
justified ruling it but he doesn't fully
acknowledge the extent to which British
previous relationship dating back to 18
a 01 had contributed to making it just
the mess that he was now using as a
justification for conquering the country
mill thus admits as I mentioned that the
anarchy in a wad was partly i quote
morally accountable unquote to British
rule and known to be the case he goes on
to say by man who knew it well what he
doesn't say there is that he was the
responsible official under the court of
directors of the East India Company
charged with the oversight of the
princely states from 1828 this was his
day job from 1828 on he was responsible
in London under the court of directors
for managing relations with the the
princely states of India including moon
so this was him that was basically
provide
the orders and the directives that from
1828 to 1858 shaped British
relationships with a wad probably should
have mentioned that in the essay okay so
problematic as this argument is in short
of its cultural orientalism I still want
to argue that Mills argument begins to
address one serious gap in our
strategies of humanitarian assistance
that is what about those devastations
that cannot be readily addressed by a
quick in-and-out intervention designed
to liberate and oppressed people from
the clutches of foreign oppression or a
domestic genocide or catastrophe
sometimes it works nicely that is that
one can intervene and then come back out
and the result is the country can get
back on its own feet and rule itself
that sort of happened in Portugal in
1846 Bangladesh came pretty much on its
own after the Indians rescued them from
the Pakistanis and there are a bunch of
others but many we know are not like
that then or in the contemporary world
certainly not Somalia for many years
Liberia couldn't govern itself nor can
Sierra Leone NORC of the Congo these are
failed states in the modern parlance and
they're not suited to one of these quick
interventions you go in you go out
you've solved the problem you got rid of
the horrible tyrant we're hoping that's
the case with Libya today as you know
the r2p mandate was cancelled by the
Security Council they're on their own at
this point though they'll certainly
receive plenty of help from NATO but for
quick interventions don't work in all
these cases so then what do you do how
does a country later become self
governing how do you empower locals to
be self-governing if the intervenors
cannot or will not commit how should one
should want to intervene and if
Outsiders do intervene who will prevent
Imperial exploitation we know these
things have been exploited in the past
we don't have clear answers but some of
the literature on multilateral
peacebuilding to which Nicholas and I
have contributed argues that under some
circumstances Outsiders can help
establish a self determining effective
government
it can do so in most importantly when it
enters on the basis of an agreed-upon
negotiated peace settlement supported by
the factions and then the outsiders are
facilitators helping to make that
agreement work and we can look at places
like Namibian Salvador Cambodia
Mozambique even East Timor and say you
know it's it's going better than it was
before with the help of the United
Nations through multilateral peace
building that help them reconstruct a
bureaucracy in a court system maybe hold
an election maybe get an economy back on
its feet those are working relatively
well but we can point to equal number of
failures Rwanda Bosnia for many years
Angola for a decade Liberia for a decade
Somalia still today subject to
interventions the African Union is there
the Kenyans just crossed the border the
Americans they were 92 that UN was there
in 93 none of it seems to have done any
real good so what can we say well one
thing we can say is that you really need
that negotiated settlement that's a good
sign if they can really agree to a
treaty that's a very good sign then you
can facilitate it if you don't have that
because the party simply cannot agree
but you intervene nonetheless let's say
to stop a genocide under those
circumstances you can make the situation
better by adopting some of the rules
that Noah Feldman in his book on Iraq
talked about that is having the
occupation be seen as trustees for the
people making efforts after they try to
establish law and order for
accountability mechanisms that are set
up to protect freedom of speech so they
will be feedback from locals who feel
that they might be disadvantaged or
harmed by the occupation and then you
start a process where you then start to
negotiate with factions to transfer
power eventually toward a national
election which then if it goes well
enough will be your legitimate excuse to
leave the country as we are now last
after many many years doing and but not
done as well as Feldman would have hoped
it had been done at the same time it's
not enough just to have good negotiating
you also have to have real resources on
the table to try to make a difference
and in the work that Nicholas and I have
done we've argue that multilateral multi
national peace building on the cheap as
a prescription for failure one needs to
have as much just as much not more but
just as much international capacity to
counterbalance local levels of hostility
and the local level of poverty and and
administrative incapacity you need to
have the right amount of a foreign
presence too much and it becomes
colonial too little and you have a
situation like Rwanda in 1994 where the
international peacekeepers there could
watch as a genocides broke out right in
their midst with no real effective way
to deal with it and the third important
feature is that the international
community needs a legitimate
multilateral voice and here with all of
its all of to oversee the process and
with all of its flaws the Security
Council is still the best candidate we
have for this it's a group that
represents five very powerful countries
ten more that are not so powerful it
always has representatives from each of
the continents Africa Asia Latin America
Europe North America or on it it
includes some differences of
civilizations it used to have more
communist the very few left it had
capitalists that is the United States UK
and France it had different cultures
different religions when they come
together and there is no veto from a
permanent member and therefore more
votes least nine from the elected
members they have a reasonable capacity
to say that they are speaking for the
international community and a word that
we usually put in quotation marks is has
some to both theoretical and political
reality to it when they speak in that
fashion that doesn't mean they always
take the right decision but the fact
that they do come together is
politically significant so Security
Council to oversee an effort at
negotiation to bring the parties
together and if not a clear plan way to
listen to the population and then the
adequate level of peacebuilding
assistance can sometimes make a
difference and that can deal with some
interventions that don't have a quick
easy in and out factor and is a
significant replacement for the
imperialism of the 19th century and can
be guaranteed to have a more
multilateral less exploitative character
attached to it even though it's far from
perfect so let me stop here and conclude
I hope this debate over the past few
weeks with john stuart mill has shown
that non-intervention and intervention
in some sense are two sides of the same
coins many of the same concerns about
national security collective
self-determination and humanitarian
protection that provide the very best
arguments for non-intervention turned
around provide arguments for sometimes
overriding and sometimes disregarding
the non-intervention norm a few other
things to be learned from mill his his
his method is an interesting one his
method is practical reason that is he
doesn't build on formula he's not a
philosopher and any strict sense of that
term developing abstract principles that
can simply be applied to cases he argues
that every case has to be explored in
its detail to understand its
significance only in the actual case
does he see an argument of justification
no abstract recipe or principle can be
applied and I think that's a useful
lesson also important is Mills practical
reason outlines for us of an array of
varying ethics for intervention in
modern discourse were tending to
assimilate all discussion of
interventions into humanitarian
intervention and then some do meet the
casualty threshold and others do not we
are impoverishing and flattening a
discourse on intervention now concern
for casualties is always relevant both
their casualties and our casualties but
it's not the end of the story to give
one example which nations do not need to
suffer a genocide to have a claim to
independence from other larger nations
that are attempting to rule them to
radically within a single piece of
national territory so let me sum up for
mill in my view he offers us logical
plausible reasons for both non
intervention intervention but when I've
looked into his historical examples the
ones that he uses I have to say that
most of them don't do quite the work
that he wanted some do some don't most
of them actually leaned against the way
that he was trying to use them to
justify intervention
internationalized Civil War counter
interventions are fraught with many
harms so manifestly of course is benign
unilateral imperialism but if it can be
done well responsible outsiders in my
opinion should be permitted to intervene
after a just defensive war in order to
reform for the sake of a more stable
peace think of the occupation of Germany
in 1945 if we can find responsible
intervenors protracted civil wars should
be mediated genocides and other r2p harm
should be stopped when we can get proper
authorization to do so and some
secession should be recognized and
assisted but you'll note this is an
increasingly long and therefore i would
say worrisome list we need to keep in
mind the million presumptions and the
last two lessons that come very strongly
from mill is that don't intervene unless
there are very strong reasons to
override or disregard and if we do make
sure that we are prepared to leave
behind a self-sustaining peace that
allows genuine self determination and a
sovereign capacity to rule or else
you'll be morally responsible for
another Civil War despotism or
imperialism just as millward now let's
stop there thank
thank you I as always I welcome your
questions and comments and suggestions
here I'll point to people Alaska meter
isms unless you would like to okay
perfect okay Joe great surprise to me
quality however I'm fascinated by the
six different reasons powerful reasons
were little gave for not intervening who
and it seems to me you've shown us that
milk himself undercut are subverted
virtually every one of these to follow
to be wined up in a very interesting
point when you save as you just did that
intervention is to science intervention
and non-intervention are those sides of
the same coin Oh God so my question
really is what is the utility of the
word intervention should we be in search
of some other word or some other concept
notion of intervention
intervals are as valuable as you have
suggested Google's lecture series only
thing has mailed himself suggests should
we be struggling for some other concepts
some other words some other description
of what it is that bothers I i I'm I'm
acutely sensitive to your concern if I
could remember the exact words out quota
mom would think I think Talleyrand once
said that intervention and
non-intervention is the same word but
but I can't give you the quote in French
but in a right he is one of the great
most wonderful cynical diplomats of of
any age so I don't regard them as a
source of moral guidance I do regard him
as a source of brilliant rhetoric and
here's you know I don't think we can
escape from a language that is you know
around these words since 1859 and
earlier he's not the very first and and
it does convey you know a dictionary of
idea of you know when you should come
between a government and its own people
that notion of intervention and that it
has to be justified now i would love to
think that we could come up with a
formula we don't have one of the the
legal community as i mentioned have
struggled with this and then I I
couldn't say more praise for that
Supreme Court opinion of Canada I it's
that tackle that better than anything
I've seen any of us would have been
happy to put our name as a Canadian
Supreme Court justice to that in my view
at least in my opinion uh and they
haven't solved that either because the
these these terms are subject to
contestation what is the people you know
how much is intervention and what we
have from Millwood I like is that he
goes beyond that he gives up some real
principles that we can apply he gives us
some examples that we can apply it to he
gives us typical situations
that we can bounce off of you know these
are cases that we can think about in our
mind no formula but we can think you
know when we attempt to stop a civil war
about the kind of arguments that he
gives us for Portugal you know or we can
think about Hungary when we think about
whether people should ever be freed and
I think that's quite valuable and within
them there are some criteria that he
gives us and the best we can do is keep
them in mind rules of thumb and examples
so cases and rules of thumb that in our
own mind we apply to cases which we will
debate and sometimes disagree about but
have a vocabulary and a grammar where we
might be able to more closely approached
the terms of agreement and in my view
that's about the best that we can do I
would love to see something better I
haven't found it yet my book will not
deliver something much better as you've
accurately pointed out I am million I
hope in a few of his virtues but in all
of the difficulties he faces too but I
want to give some rules of thumb some
guidelines and cases that we can draw
upon when we debate you know we just
went into Libya what about Syria you
know what Elliot Abrams has a piece that
he's circulating this week from the
Council on Foreign Relations where he's
making a case for heavy action into
Syria in my view he hasn't looked at a
lot of concerns that mill would have
about you know whether we need to leave
this up to independence struggle and how
representative and how broad the
opposition movement is there and so I
think he gives us a lot of reasons for
caution but is a debate will continue so
I don't have a clear crisp social
science or political science answer even
though I'm going to crank a bit of data
through this thing at one point or
another to see what comes out but it's
not going to be strict rules and the
lawyers haven't come up with them the
the ethicists haven't either and so we
we practitioners a practical reason I
think won't but we'll come up with some
good cases that's my hope of Paul
so for example which intervention or
policy and what we should be thinking
about what in particular situations with
sometimes their internal but sometimes
involve two states after all you know
post the session we might describe that
whole country's now their international
war soon so I similar about this weather
trying to hold on this is a discrete
area mmm it's actually where you end up
you are you really inviting us to say
well well there is no such discrete area
the same sets of concerns that manual
security policy or our policy wherever
forces user gonna have to think about
these things aren't an achievement but
there's nothing special about the
casualties arise from Wars person
casualties that arrived from an
international War II the question for us
should we intervene or should we take
side or should we be neutral so I wonder
if the language of neutrality for
example listen actually and someone
never the same territory and push us to
think about is there some common maybe
some in some sense this is the language
of ethics and politics and you know
national security humanitarian
protection collective rights these are
familiar concerns from all of our
political discourse in foreign policy
even in some respects and domestic
politics you know when we think of what
are the right right so the a mesh which
has come up in Pennsylvania again
all these issues are about collective
rights at the same time and individual
rights and whoo-hoo you know what sort
of schooling or health care is required
you know all these cases come up in that
kind of way so they're not just
disjointed from them the one thing that
makes is somewhat different is that here
we're talking about whether to intervene
between a government in a government of
a state and the people that inherit and
habit that territory I didn't use the
word citizens at this point so we're
talking about that notion of
intervention a little difference between
deciding whether or not we'll support
one state that's attacked another state
in an interstate war it's a it's a it's
a it's a different phenomenon one can
see and some different rules apply to it
and the rules are sensitive to the
special value that we give to at least
that Mel Gibson that I think is
important to internal self determination
that is the right of a people to shape
its own existence within its own borders
it doesn't have the same right with
regard to you know it could be a
commercial dispute a territorial dispute
or other in another state that's
something totally international this is
asking us to go inside something where
individuals constitute themselves in a
collective way and that's a very
important set of concerns and that's why
he wants us and I think we should to
have strong barriers to intervening in
this kind of a conflict that is internal
to a country we have Prudential and
other barriers to join in one side of a
war or another side of a war interstate
more over who knows what commerce you
name it but for that historically there
have been all sorts of discretion that's
involved there and we're not quite so
much involved in thinking about the
constitutive character of what a people
is if they're engaged in an interstate
war we assume that their governments are
representing them in those circumstances
do they overlap yes we gave one case
where they overlapped if you're in a
legitimate war of self-defense okay and
you succeed in pushing back the agree
reser to the border mill makes a strong
case that you can keep going to
overthrow a government if it's likely to
start a war all over again so these do
overlap in that way but I think there is
to the other side you know just this
past two weeks the u.s. is basically
taking the position leaving sort of
these building activities that is any
insight from yeah in my view they're
there they're quite strong they're quite
high you know the old Powell doctrine
you know you break it you bought it the
Pottery Barn doctrine is quite real with
regard to interventions if one country
intervenes in another country it has in
significant ways radically interfered
with the relationship between the people
and its government if it was
illegitimate if the government was
oppressive or Jenna Seidel then it's
legitimate to do so but it has stepped
in and for the standpoint of the people
having destroyed the government the
intervenors are temporarily willy-nilly
the governor of the country and have the
responsibilities that any government has
two persons that are dependent upon it
and these are very strong
responsibilities in international law
you know we have we have
laws of occupation that detail those
responsibilities and they are you know
laws connected with maintaining law and
order and providing health care and
providing adequate supplies of food and
the necessary policing and return for
that you're allowed to tax them but
you're not allowed to change any laws so
it's a little outdated I think the
responsibilities go beyond that today
and the way that go beyond that is that
there are some laws that you should
change if you're if you're intervening
in a genocidal regime you should
dismantle the genocidal laws or policies
that justified the intervention and the
most important thing is that you're a
temporary trustee I think Noah Feldman's
little book presents it quite nicely it
was what should have happened in Iraq
rather than what did happen in Iraq but
it's a nice little book on that and he
talks about those responsibilities of
trustee ship most importantly then you
know providing accountability by
creating mechanisms by which the local
scale playing free speech and then a
transition toward local
self-determination and that I think is
the modern and in that respect there is
a there is a credibility to mill despite
the weaknesses that are so obvious in
his argument with regard to hood that
the only justification of foreigners
temporarily controlling and other people
is the assistance they can give them to
make that as short as possible so they
can rule themselves so I think that's
some of the ethos that has to come from
intervention not the way he did it
unilaterally it's bound to be exploited
and of course is orientalist view of the
East is as no credibility but the idea
of responsibility does you love you the
gentleman the far back yes
John my wife and I are our community
here I'm not clear still on some
definitions of words nation state
especially when they're used together
nation state or who are they all talking
about the same thing or some
distinctions and also when you mention
civilized countries civilized government
will verify civilized in those terms you
know the one of the old ideas that is
you know what a nation is a is a group
of people with a common collective
identity sometimes based on heritage
blood usually culture but also sometimes
civic our nation for example its its
founding essence is the Constitution so
nations have that quality of addressing
that the commonality of the people state
is the ideal representation of the legal
powers or the at least established
powers that a government brings to it
that are then part of the international
system and recognized as such by others
those are the simple ideas behind nation
and state they're often used
synonymously for mill and others they
were separate a nation was a real thing
a commonality among a people and if you
had more than one in a country got into
trouble or there was no nation then
you're also in trouble but for most of
the modern discourse that we see for
example in the newspaper their use is
the same thing but for him they were
distinct than they had analytic
significance for him civilized at a very
clear meaning to his credit civilized
didn't mean white Christian or
capitalist or anything else to his
credit but it did mean something very
clear to him it meant a rule of law
system where people were ruled on the
basis of known a priori rules that were
judged on the basis of public reason
with relatively impartial institutions
so you the the law was what ruled and
second of all a technocratic culture
that took on board modern science and
was capable therefore of engaging
technically with the physical world
around it in a productive way so those
were the two that was civilized for him
now we all know that civilized has also
been a code word for whatever the
imperialists did and it's been used in
that context so you know we are
civilized and anybody we don't like is
uncivilized you know this is the way
that rogue states are often used in the
modern world too but for him and had a
relatively clear meaning it doesn't mean
it was justifiable but for him had a
relatively clear meaning in the rest of
our literature it's totally open ended
it basically means whoever's domin at
the time calls what they do civilized so
the bar where the Western barbarians
were uncivilized to Islamic states
definitely in the seventh and eighth and
ninth century there's very amusing
descriptions of Western feudal elites
showing up at quartz they're they're
hilarious descriptions of them of the
same sort that Europeans made of
africans and asians in the 19th century
but for him and had a technical clear
meaning um one more yes this gentleman
right here in the winter David Simon I
wanted to go back to something along the
lines of the first two questions or hook
you move it on the meaning of the word
intervention but a slightly different
direction I guess I'm wondering if the
way you've spoken about intervention has
not exclusively but primarily taken out
of the sense of military intervention
except perhaps we talked about that
state building
but what about and that's after Brett
the government has fallen this should
replaced for the question I have is
about does Neil give us any guidance and
what we might call meddling or without
working to build civil society in the
country with a desk by 2 i'm giving aid
to the opposition well there are a host
of things away yeah i was tempted to get
into that effect that it but it as your
question the tone of it suggests it's a
it's a it's a very large rock with a
whole lot underneath it and mill is he
is predominantly talking about military
intervention but in the literature
including some of those un documents
that i referred to they talk about any
form of intervention cultural economic
criticism could be intervention or
unequal doses of foreign a discriminated
between one country or another or
conditional foreign aid one or another
and so in much of the literature that
comes down as intervention if if if i
had included it this would have been at
least six lectures rather than three
there's a lot to be said about it but i
decided to stick with the million idea
of forcible intervention and also so i
could track the legal idea of
intervention intervention and internet
in the clinics in the kind that i'm
referring to an international law begins
with either a blockade okay or
compulsory multilateral sanctions both
of those enter under Chapter 7
requirements for authorization and
anything let's call it tougher than that
you know troops moving across borders
bombing all of that with regard to
assisting foreign forces you have to be
able to show and Paul I think you must
run an amicus brief on this for
Nicaragua right a long time ago you have
to say you're correct me but you've
gotta show and
variety of standards either a concerted
funding okay and support or a later
standard is direction of those foreign
intervening covert forces or and then
the ICC document both those things come
into play but the Nicaragua case the
tightest case and the Bosnia case
produced different standards in
international law and the ICC brings
them all together Koopman but there
again it's substantial direction and
support for a military intervening force
so that's where I draw the line
everything less than that not trading
not financing criticizing an
international law those are all
discretionary you can break law you can
break the WTO if you stop trading with
the country but it's not illegal under
international law right so that's where
I've drawn my line it's a very good
question but that'd be a good book for
somebody else to undrawn that line